(upbeat music)
(audience clapping)
- Nice to see you.
- Last time we were so separated.
- I know!
- That's how long it's been.
- We had the Covid thing.
- I know!
- We're allowed to be a little closer.
- I like this.
- So, it's nice to see you,
and congrats on the little one.
- Thank you, thank you so much.
(audience cheering)
- How's the family doing overall?
- So good.
She is such a light and a joy.
And having a new baby in the house,
you know what it's like.
(crowd awws)
They love her so much and,
- I know, is there any jealousy?
Just cause it's a new, you know.
- It's weird because I thought
they would either like, you know,
be very mad at her for just existing
- Yeah.
- Or they would like want
so much attention from me.
But they actually love her so much
and they want so much attention from me.
So, it's both.
And it has a lot to with her, obviously.
But they still shower her with love.
Every bath in the sink they crowd around
and Miles is in like
this crazy kissing phase
where he's like just kind
of practicing a little bit
on everything.
- Oh my God.
But my daughter did that to Remi
whenever she just kept kissing him.
- Yeah.
- She just thought he was so cute too.
And I was like, baby, it's getting weird.
- I know, I know.
(audience laughs)
I know.
And so Miles, if it's
like six in the morning
I feel the kisses.
(Kelly laughs)
and he thinks I'm asleep.
But it's so cute.
He'll do my like top lip and bottom lip.
And then with Estie he's just like, ah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- All in.
- He's like, this feels fine.
- Yeah, he loves it.
He's like so affectionate.
- I heard that y'all actually
did you throw them a party, like
- I did.
- before Esti came home?
- Yeah. I had this big grand idea.
So I had a scheduled C-section
so I thought it was gonna happen
on like a Saturday morning or something.
So I planned this big Scooby-Doo party.
The kids love Scooby-Doo right now.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And the old ones only.
They're very crazy about
it being the old, old ones.
(Kelly laughs)
And so I bought balloons and Scooby Snacks
and all this stuff for
my bedroom 'cuz they love
when they get a chance
to sleep in our bed, so.
- Yeah.
- I had that planned out.
But then of course the C-section
just came out of nowhere,
and so I wasn't able to do it.
So I did it after she was born
and they were just so,
so happy. And I wanted
- It's such a smart idea
though, for the older kids.
- Yeah. I wanted them to make,
I wanted them to know.
that I wasn't gonna forget about them.
- Yeah, and not resent the baby.
- Yes, exactly.
- Her name is Esti, which
I thought was so cool.
- Yes, thank you.
- And I know I found out over text.
Why? 'Cuz I asked.
- Yeah.
- But, tell everybody like
where that name came from.
- Yeah, I was actually just,
we were on vacation where
we got married in Italy
and I was looking up at the hotel
and I kept seeing the Estee, Estee of it
and then I was like I love the name Estee.
And then just playing around with it.
And then we came up
with Esti and then John,
after we named her Esti,
learned that it was actually
his great grandmother's name.
- Which is the craziest part of the story.
- Yeah.
- 'Cuz I've never heard
this name in my entire life.
- And you're like, oh, it's a family name.
- I know.
- No, I'd never heard of Esti.
- Yeah.
- It was, yeah, I guess
that maybe it was Esther
and then they turned it to Esti.
- That's cute.
- Yeah.
- I love that.
- I love how it was familiar
and you didn't even know.
- Yeah. And then of course
I'm sure you're the same way.
You want them to all sound
good together and have the
- Yes.
- You know, so it's yeah.
it just fit.
- I was the weird mom who was like,
has to be an R 'cuz River and
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Yeah. I was like, I
thought it was cute, anyway.
(Chrissy laughs)
But they're great names.
Anyway. So last time you were here,
Miles and Luna were super busy.
So are they still doing everything?
All the things?
- More than everything.
They did more than
- That's mine too.
- I ever did as a child.
They do gymnastics, ballet, little ninjas.
Tee-ball.
- They do Tee-ball, right?
- Yeah. T-ball is like
Miles' thing right now.
It's so, it's so much fun.
- Little ninjas? My kids would love that.
- Little ninjas is, it's just like,
it's all the stuff they do on your couch
but in a controlled environment.
(crowd laughs)
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- That's my son. Yes.
I'm like, you're going to break stuff.
- It's genius.
- Yeah.
- It's such a smart idea
with all the padding
and everything necessary, yeah.
It's really cute.
- Oh that's awesome.
- It's so fun.
- It keeps you busy though.
- Yes.
- I was like my mom was so lucky
she didn't have to do any of this.
- I know.
- Like, (laughs) like
- Yeah.
- And not to mention all the
events at school and stuff.
Every holiday is celebrated
so they can learn
about different cultures and stuff.
So they always have something different.
- Which is cool 'cuz it's inclusive,
but at the same time, you're like,
and now it's this month.
- I know, I know.
- Yeah.
I love that it's inclusive.
- I know.
- Yeah.
- My kids look forward to Friday.
They're like, there's
nothing today, right?
(Kelly laughs)
And I'm like, yes.
There's nothing today.
- It's awesome 'cuz I like them learning
about all the different things.
It's just hilarious.
'Cuz I do feel like there is
a holiday for everything.
- There is. There is.
- Yeah.
So wait, who is louder at tee-ball games?
Is it you or John?
- It's me for sure.
- Okay.
- Yeah. I grew up watching baseball.
- Kind of don't know why
I asked you that question
(Chrissy laughs)
because he is like walking Ambien to me.
- I know.
(crowd laughs)
Thank you for saying. I know.
- Yeah. He's very chill.
- I know, it's just him.
- And, and he's, no,
he's just super chill.
- Yeah, I don't think he's
ever gotten mad at me.
Like truly.
I really don't like, I mean he has,
but he doesn't show it at least.
- Wow.
(crowd laughs)
- But like, yeah.
It's pretty wild.
- He is very even keel.
Yeah. I gotta-
- He is.
- He should write a book, yeah.
- Yeah, I know.
- For people like us. (laughs)
- And then everyone's like, yeah,
people like that though it's festering
and it's gonna burst.
I'm like, no, it's not in there.
(crowd laughs)
It's like totally just not.
- Yeah. Yeah he's very chill.
- Yeah he is.
- So I don't even know
why I asked you that.
- No, it's okay.
- Yeah, of course you're
the one at the game
'cuz he's probably just
like, he does a nod.
- Yeah. And plus I'm not sure if he, like
I love baseball so much
and he's just like kind of yeah,
he's passive with, he doesn't mind.
He's one of those people that's like
I want both teams to win.
Like even in football and stuff.
(audience laughs)
Yeah. But I love.
I love hyping everybody up though,
like the other team.
Except they're four and five.
So come on. Yeah.
- Yeah. That's so cute.
(Chrissy laughs)
I love these like, everyone's a winner.
(audience cheers)
So after another baby,
are you making sure to
make time for yourself?
because you're outnumbered now?
- I know.
- You and John.
- I know. It's fun though.
I love the chaos of it.
The house is so noisy and
I really, really love it.
I don't really go out and do
a lot of things for myself.
If they can come to the house and do it.
Like if I can get, I have
a masseuse chiropractor
that I've been seeing since Luna was born.
So like seven years now.
He helped me, like, he
helped flip her in my belly.
His name's Dr. Berlin.
He like pushed her, like moved my muscles
massaged my muscles
- They're incredible.
- Helped slip her entire body.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
- And so I've been seeing
him for six, seven years now.
And for the all seven years,
Every time he comes over,
which is about once a week maybe or more
if I was trying to move the
baby around or something,
we will do a massage
and watch a murder doc
at the same exact time.
(audience laughs)
Like that is, or a podcast or whatever.
He's my, like
- What?
- He's my what other husband, basically.
(audience laughs)
I spend so much time with him at night.
- Wait. So wait, during a massage
you're like while you're relaxing
you like to listen to murder?
- I don't like, like,
soft soothing sounds.
- Oh.
- I like crazy podcasts
and I like true crime and,
even if I get a facial,
I'll bring in my phone
and she'll be like
"you wanna listen to murder, don't you?"
and then I'll say yes.
And she goes, it sucks because
then you fall asleep during the facial
and I'm stuck listening
to murder by myself.
(audience laughing)
(Kelly clapping)
- Which is so weird.
- She hates it.
She hates my stuff.
(Kelly laughs)
But yeah, I'm just like, I love crime.
I don't know.
- My friends are all like that.
Like all my girlfriends
are like this as well.
- I know.
- And I'm just like, I think, I go down.
I need to see the
brighter side of humanity.
- Yeah.
- Not the worst.
Yeah.
- I don't know.
It's very
- It's fascinating to people.
- I like things that I can just like
listen to mindlessly.
I like to solve things.
Like of course Serial was so big
to me to follow that case along.
And I always thought I'd be involved
in criminal justice somehow.
So like for me, I really love,
I don't know, I just, I
love every aspect of it.
I love watching the shows.
- Not alone.
There's millions of you.
- I know What's wrong with us.
- It's a huge thing.
No, it's cool.
Yeah. I like, you know, Talladega Nights.
(Chrissy laughing)
I like to laugh.
- I know. You're like Ted Lasso.
- Yeah. I like Ted Lasso.
But my friends are like, it's too happy.
And I'm like, what the
hell is wrong with you?
- I know, I know.
- Anyway, speaking of self-care,
so you're doing work
with something called,
and I've actually heard of this.
I'm so mad at myself 'cuz
somebody told me about it
when my kids were born,
especially River my first one,
but Cord blood registry.
- Yes.
- I'm so mad I didn't do it
because it was so new to me.
And nobody I knew had ever done it.
- [Chrissy] Yeah.
- But I really wish I
would've done it now.
- I know it was new to us too.
I remember around the
time that I had Luna,
I was asking around for someone to,
I'll try anything if if
has a chance of working
if it doesn't hurt you.
So when everyone was saving their placenta
to make into pills and stuff,
I was like looking for
somebody to do that.
It's incredible.
- The stem cells.
- Yeah, you save the stem cells,
they basically when your baby is born,
they clip off like a four
inch piece of the cord,
the umbilical cord, and
they save it in this bank
in Tucson, Arizona.
And those stem cells can be used to treat
over 80 different conditions.
- A plethora.
- Right now, 80.
As you know, like science is ever evolving
and it's just amazing.
- I have one of those autoimmune things
and I actually do stem cells.
- Yeah?
- Like I, I do that.
- That's incredible.
- So that's why I think
and it's been extremely helpful for me.
- Yeah.
No, it's like a little kit.
I packed it in my baby bag.
I handed it to the doctor when I was like
about to be cut open.
- Yeah.
- I was just like, here you go.
(Kelly laughs)
And then they just flip up on the kit,
cut the piece send it off and it's done.
And then you have it for
the rest of your life.
And it'll will help the
siblings, it can help.
If your kids get sick, it's incredible.
- I just feel so dumb for not doing it.
But I think it's really important
that you're talking about it.
But is it true that you like to go
to Dave and Busters?
I still live at Dave Busters on tour.
- We go every 10 days I would say.
- I didn't even know
there was one near here.
- Yeah.
There's Hollywood Highland.
- Look at John. He's like,
kids get off the game.
- This game, like, encases
you with sound and vibration.
And I fell asleep. This
is right after we had Esti
and I still fell asleep inside of it.
(Chrissy and Kelly laugh)
- Are you one of those people
that could fall asleep everywhere?
- Anywhere. So is John, obviously.
(Kelly sighs)
But yeah, we can fall asleep anywhere.
- I'm not.
- We go early in the morning.
We go around like 9:30,
10 and then get in.
We put our stuff down,
order food, go play,
come back, have lunch and
then we're out after lunch
before the big rush.
- Yeah.
- But, we love it.
We never like,
don't even do it for like the tickets.
We just go and we leave.
- Yeah.
(Chrissy laughing)
The ticket thing is funny
'cuz you always end up,
it doesn't matter where you are.
Putt putt, wherever you
are, and you're getting.
- Chinese finger trap.
- Well no and it's just
like, and it costs you
150 tickets and you're
like it costs like $5.
- [Chrissy] I know, I know.
(Chrissy laughs)
- I just think it's funny.
But the kids get so excited.
Like we're getting those 150 tickets.
- I know, I know.
- So okay.
- Then there's randomly like a Kitchen Aid
for 75,000.
(Kelly laughing)
- Yeah. It's like a random pot.
(Kelly clapping)
- It really Was a Kitchen Aid last year.
(Chrissy laughs)
- Okay. We do love David Busters. I do.
And Putt putt. Okay.
I realized that you and I
never competed in a game
on the show. So do you wanna do it?
You don't have a choice.
- Oh my God.
- Will you play a game with me?
- Okay.
(audience cheers)
Yeah! I'm in!
- Great!